[Music]
lame parents news that's us
you're the only parents I don't think
I'm lame though that blue hair I'm not
lame
so just part I thought Isaak hated her
blue hair hate it he just did it from
the bottomless guts his first diamond
blue he was like ma you don't look like
a mom anymore oh good that's millennial
talk for after you man
do you know Britney Spears kids even
called her lame oh my god Britney Spears
was like yeah my kids always told me I'm
lame and I'm like Britney Spears that's
[ __ ] crazy like if your mom was Dolly
Parton or some [ __ ] yeah she's not lame
yeah but it's like old music you know
yeah right and the kids are like you're
lame betcha when she had kids like
wasn't she like within the prime golden
era dude imagine Kanye's Kim they're
gonna be like ah you're so embarrassing
yeah oh yeah yeah but I would definitely
call Kanye pretty lame though you're
never exempt from kids thinking you're
lame oh honey is cool but he's still
kind of lame yeah like he has those lame
qualities but he just makes a dope yeah
I did the only way is if you had kids
when you're like 13 oh then one or 23
your kids 10 don't think you're lame I
promise no matter what you don't have
kids when you're 13 though or 18 I know
but now your language all now are you
like 20 or something you guys stay with
them fill in my 20 yeah stay within the
London Eye wow that was a double whammy
over here now is only for him what is
that all I'm saying is you got to stay
within the lame air okay you're lame
people anyways a good minute by us see
kids oh [ __ ] did you even get there for
real or did your mom pass there's a lot
of you work hard to get in there it's
the scandal all of all the Indian kids
that worked really hard to get in there
oh then many parents are filling out job
applications for their grown children
what I know I hate this baby in culture
I don't mind it you know why a second
me too because all of our kids in this
room are gonna [ __ ] Massacre and
[ __ ] go oh you're your own kid
alright not my child what if that
becomes the standard enormous and they
all look at it like man what's wrong
with you oh you did your they actually
don't succeed because they don't know
how to connect with them yeah because
the culture completely changed with the
cellphones and a little kid true we had
this long has talked with Isaac about
why we feel like he's not ready for a
phone not that he wants it right now is
just like it kind of came up in
conversation yeah and he was just saying
it's a hard conversation yeah and you
don't want to beat your kids that's
easier I know this is why it's easier
but it's so damaging for words dude cuz
I said so but that also makes a dumb kid
that's how I grew up and I [ __ ] hated
it I do want to hear in a conversation
was the conversation so we were just
talking about how like yes everyone
might have a cell phone right now but
there's just so much power and this
small little break that I got you make
it sound so fun I know well you mean
there's power in here mom are you
[ __ ] really you should have just
called them out like you want to jack
off don't you just be a asian mom with
it we ended up talking about how like in
my opinion there's a more bad than good
on the internet people might not agree
with that but I I feel it strongly about
that that there's more bad than good on
the internet so yes you can go out there
and learn all these things watch videos
and they've become super intelligent
because there's so much information on
the internet but the majority of that
it's gonna be bad cuz and you're gonna
go on social media you're gonna have
your friends talking about you or each
other and it's just a lot of spread of
negativity do you like how to go on the
computer at all so he goes on certain
site like computer game sites but like
for example he plays fortnight and I
tell him like he's not he's he's not
allowed to speak to strangers online at
all like I'm and I tell him like you
don't the reai tell them the reasons why
I don't tell him to Washington Michael
Jackson documentary he'll be fun he
actually asked me what's leaving
Neverland cuz he saw it on on the TV say
it's not real but this could happen to
you and then
ever since he was little I always
stressed so much about that whole like
the possibility of pedophilia and all
that like has anyone ever touch you like
you always gotta tell me and like I tell
I tell him to like how these people
groom the kids and how they make them
feel like they're responsible for what's
happening or like you know they make
them feel guilty or like they make him
feel like it's a good thing or whatever
the [ __ ] I tell I try to tell him
everything from both sides because I
want him to be as knowledgeable as you
possibly can especially when it comes to
the whole social media stuff I tell him
like yeah it could be awesome that all
your friends are on there but like
statistically teenagers that have cell
phones before high school they are
statistically way more depressed later
on in life in so I'm like I am trying to
protect you I'm trying to protect your
mental health I want you to be a nice
healthy adult that in like you know once
you want to explore all the bad side of
the Internet you can go ahead once your
maturely ready for that ever right now
your brain can't handle that if he goes
can I have a cell phone what's that
really good at avoiding conversation and
the important parts of parenting I
probably bet you you're gonna
that's what terrifies me about having
kids though because all the stupid [ __ ]
I did even with them telling me not to
do those things and I still did them I'm
like oh [ __ ] I should be dead like how
is it how is my chair near miss that you
got to learn how to care less I want him
to make mistakes too right cuz I've
always been afraid of making mistakes
and failing in life and I don't wanna
have my kid be the same yeah so I'm like
it's okay to get things wrong it's okay
I almost got kidnapped though no joke
Hawaii and I was 17 [ __ ] oh my god you
were dumb I know oh they're gonna take
you up I guess I didn't have friends so
I didn't know I was really behind
socially like super behind I was very
ahead academically like straight A's AP
classes but like socially how did you
almost get kidnapped
okay sighs you want some coconuts yeah
that's how it happened did we get the
finish tips they're doing hey house
let's go want these even let me try to
get you in the car
I begged him too hard in the news like
you were I mean like where would they
hide you I was 17 and I was all like but
her because I'm a teenager and I'm with
my family for vacation and I'm like
that's always laying I'd have no friends
here and like all my friends are at home
right on have friends but like you know
the two friends I hang hung out with
they're at home and I was just like
bummed because I wasn't quite 18 I was
turning 18 that year but I wanted to do
all the things that eats a weird little
spot yeah yeah and so there was this
club that was like across the street
from my hotel that was 18 and up but I
still was in 18 and so I was gonna try
to get in and I couldn't but that was
like hey mom can I just at least walk
down like the main you know I'm like
hiki that mean like street where all the
shops are so can I at least just walk
down and like explore the shops and
she's like yeah sure just you know don't
go too far and it's nighttime
oh it's cuz she you don't get good night
yeah exactly what a rebel dude starts
talking to me and he's like this older
guy like kind of heavyset guy he's like
yeah he's like super chill and he's like
he's from Florida and he's telling me
about like the reigns of stuff and he's
just making a small chat but I'm so
lonely and like just wanting like to
talk to people yeah
dick on the spot yes no because what if
he's all like she likes me he was like
maybe in his late 30s yeah he bought me
ice cream oh he did the ice cream thing
to you too I was like sure eighteen by
not money conversation sir sure buy me
ice and then and then he's like we were
looking through the stores and I was
just like I spent some time together
yeah because he just kept talking and
watch a purse like it's a little
souvenir like a little secret shows or
whatever yeah I was like oh that's
really nice you don't have to do that
but he was like no no I want to I want
to I was like please don't and then he
bought it anyway and I was like hey
thanks I just trying to get you whatever
so we were walking and then he's like oh
I have to go to my car it's right here
and it's like this [ __ ] dork ass
parking garage they were like sure I was
like okay well bye nice meeting you and
he was like you want to come like walk
me to my car really quick and I was like
no it was like one of those movies were
like the flickering like fluorescent
lights like I was like oh I don't think
so but thank you and then he went for a
hug and I was like gotta go but yeah but
I was like later after I got home I was
like I could kidnap that guy tried to
kidnap me yeah I was he was kind of
guilting me he was like oh come on it's
just right there like I just want to say
bye little girl just right there I was
like no not here no thanks around that
corner with three other fat people from
Florida and they were gonna gang rape
yeah I have some other stuff in my car I
want to give you like that kind of stuff
[ __ ] a quaalude all right holy [ __ ]
that's scary
anything told later that I was like oh
[ __ ] my palms are sweating what probably
wasn't a nice guy
I have a daughter hope she's [ __ ]
ugliest [ __ ] so whatever he wants what
if he did that to someone else there I
know that's what I'm seeing like you
should have been like yeah I'll go we
couldn't go get this knife real quick I
didn't think about I thought what a nice
guy he's been buying me so many things
like oh I owe it to him to like watch
the nobody bites having that home cuz
what if he's like lace to your ice cream
oh no he bought it from the store
they handed it to me directly you should
have been like I'll walk you with you to
your car could tell you about my AIDS
story on my way there said something
smart if I put it together that he was
doing that I didn't even put it together
and would think with the technology out
today that kids would be smarter about
these things but they're not it's still
the same [ __ ] childhood innocence they
still expect the best out of people
they're even dumber because they're so
consumed with this that they don't get
to go out and play the way we did and we
get a lot of our street logic and common
sense from playing with kids on the
street you play with older kids they
tell you like advice and you just learn
so many things that like when I was like
typing in second or third grade no hey
when bands pull up don't get inside I'm
like no [ __ ] [ __ ] who the [ __ ] you're
trying to tell but I guess when you look
around as a lot of kids we had a safe
word no no I don't know yeah a lot of I
just did a stand-up show recently right
yeah and then there was like a younger
crowd and I used the word drive-by they
didn't know what a drive-by was you just
draw what they didn't what a [ __ ]
drunk it was like there were like
you mean drive-thru yeah and so like
literally in the crowd like half the
crowler cuz they knew what that joke was
with a drive-by think with the other
half
big didn't know what a drive-by was I
was like you know what a [ __ ] drive
by a zombie what the [ __ ] I thought was
kind of like oh [ __ ] maybe I should have
gauge the crowd a little bit better but
like a couple of kids came up to it like
what's the drive-by
I was like so that's why the other half
kind of didn't get it yeah I mean I
think that's good they were raised
pretty like sheltered I'm just kind of I
said that joke in retrospect to what
howl I brew up yeah yeah yeah yeah it
wasn't proper so like where did you do
this show Orange County is a college you
know I just realized I never told you
guys anything about the article oh yeah
tell me something like that [ __ ]
kidnapped [ __ ] story was good I
pictured everything in my head I felt
like I was there
yeah I knew which parking lot to I know
I felt like it's the one by the mall
yeah all right well it's just really
quick in case you're wondering about
this article they surveyed 1,500 us
parents of adult children aged 18 to 28
and 14 percent said that they had pools
great pulled strings of their own
professional network to secure a job for
their children and a lot of them you
go to the extreme of filling out job
applications for their grown children
that's insane old are we talking about
228 that's not teaching Amanda fish dude
in this show called Terrace house on
Netflix there was this kid that was on
one season he got on the show because
his grandma filled out the application
for him to come on the show that's how
much of a [ __ ] loser that kid was
yeah when they found out it was like
half the women girls in the house were
disgusted I don't like your that [ __ ]
lazy and this girl in the show ripped
into him
good he says I I want to come onto this
show to learn how to be independent but
every time you were coming to the house
you have new clothes on you everything
someone's buying what did you get that
it goes my dad's credit card Wow he was
swiping his dad's credit card saying
that he wanted to be independent from
his dad oh my god yeah I feel like it's
mostly boys to like the errands baby the
boys for some reason I feel that too for
some reason best true I feel that in a
lot of Asian families yes little ass
[ __ ]
[Music]